Amy Schumer Seth Rogen and Michael Pena  star and Buzz lights newest commercial  set to air during the oscars here with  bud light party super delegate Michael  Pena to talk about diversity in the  midst of the Oscars so white controversy  Bud Light debuts a new TV spot focused  on inclusion humor and of course great  promotion for its beer America is a  nation of immigrants for a smorgasbord  of cultures Korean taco togetherness and  everything bagel of unity each one of us  a different seed house beautifymeeh bud  light tells ET the ad couldn't have run  at a better time right now during the  oscars there is nothing more timely than  the conversation around diversity and  inclusion we're a poutine of harmony a  gumbo of coexistence we're a  never-ending bottomless all-inclusive  super buffet I can't do anywhere  metaphors  you